[Music]
so I'd argue that accessibility is
probably more important than saving
people from fires and stuff sometimes I
wish I had a really good fake American
accent just to really confuse people but
I don't so they already covered it but
this is not me I've not given up my
acting career to become a developer the
money's not really the same this is me
I'm not too sure I always get asked
about the other guy took this photo for
me this was done in a car park somewhere
in Perth doesn't look anything like that
when you see the original photoshop is
good through my talk I'll be referencing
a couple different URLs to save you
typing stuff madly I put them all on my
tumblr so if you want to play along with
a couple of demos that I'll be going
through like this down now and you can
see exactly how bad my code is in my
flesh rather than nice bits that i show
you in my slides and i moved to
singapore a couple of years ago I was
working for this company I just left
them one of the things I did when I
shifted here is I took on the task of
creating a global you I standard the
company I was working for jlt operate in
140 something countries around the world
we had teams just anywhere we didn't
even know how many teams that were
working on software for us at any given
time and there was no coherence anything
from one to another we had a logo that
was the same most of the time the colors
weren't any sense of you I was just lost
and branding was lost between the
different divisions and outsourced
companies and everything so stupidly I
decided to do this myself I had no
actual support really I don't recommend
doing
get help I should note actually before I
go further I don't work at the company
anymore I don't know if anyone's
actually maintaining this project all
the code is on github so you can grab it
and look at it how if you like but no
guarantees about how long it's going to
be there and I set out following the
programmers credo we do things because
we think they are easy not because we
they're easy because we thought they'll
going to be easy and classic avoidance
behavior the first thing I did setting
out to create a UI style guide was to
look into architecture because that's
exactly where you go this piece of
architecture is called the Strand this
was designed by Arthur Ericsson and it's
in robson square in vancouver erickson
followed the design philosophies of the
universal design and the idea of
universal design is that you build
something and it's just inherently able
to be used by everyone so you've got a
set of stairs where's the ramp well the
ramp is in the stairs that's just how
you do a ramp and how you do stairs
there's nothing no special accordance
made for anyone here this is just good
design and the ideas of universal design
are to make things equitable so
regardless of individual abilities
something will just work you don't have
to have legs in order to get up the ramp
needs to be flexible so irrespective of
how someone wants to use it it'll just
work William Gibson has a saying on this
like the street finds its own use for
things when we design a product that's
good anyone can pick it up and just use
it the way they want to they don't have
to read a manual it should just work in
a way that makes sense this is very
difficult of course but this is what we
aim towards
design should be simple and intuitive
they should make sense without anyone
having to explain what goes on this is
one of those things that's really easy
to discuss but it's really hard to do in
practice because what makes sense to
people changes over time my son is five
years old if I give him a touch
interface he's got no problem with it if
I give a touch interface to someone I
mean first iPhone ship with a manual
because Apple weren't sure that people
would know what to do with the thing now
we think is touch and we talk about is a
really intuitive way of doing UI design
but there's nothing really in inherently
intuitive about anything it we just have
to get into the social understanding of
how people do things so expectations
will change over time in essence so
what's simple intuitive to us now wasn't
for someone 100 years ago for example
and won't be for some 100 years from now
design should be perceptible if you
can't see it it's not there humans
develop object permanence around eight
months with young babies you can do
peekaboo that's really exciting because
you've disappeared when your hands are
in front of your eyes like wow with
interfaces it's exactly the same thing
if you can't see it if you've got a
something that shows up only on hover
it's not there so I might find it by
accident but if thats content that
someone needs to actually consume then
it's not going to be read this is one of
the big arguments against carousels for
example and because the rates for
carousels no one basically gets past the
first slide that I don't read it so when
someone insists on a carousel we say are
you happy that ninety-eight percent of
your viewers won't see anything past the
first thing if they are that's fine let
them pay the penalty design should be
tolerant and I've done a lot of work on
forms in the past and when you see
videos of testing with forms and you see
people crying because they get an error
message you understand the impact of
you doing to people let people make
mistakes let them fail in a way that's
gentle don't let them just fall and cry
because that's what happens it's one of
the problems in our industries is we
never really see the people at the other
end of the screen but keep that in your
mind when you're doing it someone's
going to have a great deal of difficulty
with this unless I think about it a bit
better design should be low effort you
shouldn't have to like do gymnastics on
the keyboard to do a keyboard shortcut
if you any Photoshop users with the the
export command it's absolutely
disgusting and the guy who came up with
it thought no one was going to use it so
he you have to like use a couple of
hands and I think your nose just to get
the the key commands right he's written
a blog post apologizing sense that you
know if they thought about a bit better
it might have been nicer the sign needs
to be appropriate for the size and space
regarded in dividual abilities having a
five-year-old and a boy I'm acutely
aware of how well-designed urinals are
in toilets because you go into them you
get the ones that are really tall and he
can walk in there there's no problem you
get the ones where the height is up here
I have to hold him so we can go later
just a simple design of having it work
for everyone adults can walk in they use
it doesn't make a difference little boys
can walk in and it's fine when you don't
use Universal Design then you notice
basically on a similar note I wasn't
really as appreciative as I could have
been until I had a a pram or stroller
and when you've got wheels and you need
to navigate through something then you
really appreciate how good ramps are and
lists and things like that otherwise
you'll just walk through life and not
really notice that much until you hurt
your foot or something to setting out to
build a framework this tells you a lot
about my own personality but I went with
no dependents
I didn't want any history any baggage
anything to hold me back my rationale
behind that is that I don't want to like
fail because someone else has written
something bad that's going to break and
I don't know what it does I won't have
some idea of what's actually going on so
the way to do that is pretty simple you
take bootstrap jquery all your different
libraries and throw them in the bin I've
got so many people who use bootstrap and
they hate it really it's taking my
opportunity again to bag bootstrap
there's nothing really in there that you
can't do yourself you just have to
really have a go the scariest thing out
of this was throwing out jquery I mean
I've been writing JavaScript since it
was released in 96-97 whenever it was I
became a fully fledged jquery friend or
something along those lines and you
don't need it anymore you've got element
query selector and query select all
that's most of what jQuery does for you
you can live without it let go of the
tethers and your life will be much
happier the first thing setting out to
create a library and following universal
design was to make sure accessibility it
was a key that meant diving into the
Aria roles I thought this was going to
be a lot harder than it was I had a
pretty good idea of how Aria things work
because I care about that anyway but
creating this library I wanted to make
every single component of it completely
accessible no excuses every line of code
everything that's rendered must be
accessible to everyone to the fullest
possible standard so it meant reading a
lot of documentation there were the good
things out of this is it's changed how I
code so instead of I've got my bem
syntax here where I've got a tab and
I've got my selected state when you use
the Aria components you don't need
anything else it actually gives you the
syntax that makes a whole lot more sense
in there and it's easy to understand
someone else's code when you're eating
this you can see right away Aria
selected is true you know what the state
of that component is it gives you a
JavaScript selector it gives you obsess
s if you need to do anything with
JavaScript it does all the work for you
this is pretty awesome and most of these
things have just been sitting there and
get ignored a bit but Aria pays off
really quickly even if you don't care
about accessibility just by following
the standards you get all these freebies
which is really nice and then again with
setting attributes through JavaScript
it's really clear what this code does
you don't really need to explain to
anyone what you doing you don't have a
half a custom class or anything thats
all i needs to understand how your CSS
works to work out how to set of selected
state or some other state when i first
got into this i got a bit crazy and did
things like this and don't do that
there's already hidden display none
slightly yeah if it's hidden I don't
want to show it on the screen right but
then you want to animate something and
it's display none so you can't do that
anymore so I quickly learnt to use like
name spacing in essence where you just
attach it to a class that's already
there then you've got the flexibility to
do things how you want I saw recently
Hayden Pickering suggested one of the
other area pseudo classes or selectors
you do in a universal so ignored what
I'm telling you in that regard that
generally speaking just be careful when
you when you're getting into this stuff
the first thing you'll want to do is
really dive into the documentation and
if you've looked at w3c documentation
it's pretty scary I mean look how
attractive this this design is really
once you make it once you've read it
fortunately I'm not the first person to
ever have done this so i mentioned
Hayden Pickering before he's got some
really awesome examples of UI components
you can just grab them exactly as they
are and pop them into your projects if
you like otherwise read his code work
out how it operates and its really good
w3c documentation does have examples
some of them a bit wrong which is why
it's a good idea to go a bit further and
find what you're doing and the thing
that you need to do is you know you need
tabs in a site so just Google Aria tabs
and get your examples from that it's not
hard just add Aria to your google search
and your life will be a whole lot easier
and everyone using your product will be
happier as well leah is right here this
is her work Thank You Leah I needed to
create a hierarchical picker we had some
really complex data and we needed a way
for people to select things we had
basically really deep nested business
units parent company local region office
office locations in a city it was just
crazy crazy trying to work it out and
the you is that was there before I got
onto the project with pretty horrendous
there are about five steps for anyone to
get through to select something so I
grabbed awesome fleet which is as
awesome as the name suggests I mean it's
2k and you've got a fully accessible by
use this thing everyone you don't need
bootstrap when you've got this it's this
is my code I was going to do a live demo
but for some reason keynote hates me at
the moment so I'm just doing this live
version instead this is a hierarchical
picker that when you start typing it
will select things for you this
structure is taking a tree view from the
REO recommendations so all the
accessibility of a treeview nested in
with the recommendations of how a
auto complete works so when you have
custom controls you don't have to just
say well it's not in the Aria spectrum
who needs accessibility just chop and
change what's in there and it makes
sense after a while it's not too hard to
wrap your head around it so the idea of
this one is you can very quickly select
what you want and then navigate down the
tree without having to know what it's
doing if you don't want to type you can
still navigate through the tree because
it's a fully accessible tree view so you
get both things at once which is great
this is a demo so it doesn't look pretty
never went to production because I left
the company before anything happen with
it but the code is there is this thing
does work you can't read that I can't
read that that's getting this is a huge
screen so my examples a little bit lost
but you meant to write it by now one of
the keys like Aria roles are any part of
accessibility making things obvious is
really important accessibility we talk
about usually in a very narrow range
where we say that here's the area stuff
you you follow the add the attributes
and you're done but it's not just that
and this is really going back to
universal design making things
intuitive's that you can actually work
out what you're doing so the universal
design principles here are simple and
intuitive perceptible low-effort rise
right size and space and that's wrapped
uppers make it obvious this is Google's
recommendation for touch sizing and this
is really what you need to know about
buttons and interactive elements
basically you need to make them big
enough before touchscreens became a
thing usually we were worried about
something that you could generally reach
with a mouse with touch we've got these
things which are really clumsy at you I
interaction and the research has been
done that we know that based on a
certain pixel
you can make something big enough that I
can tap it with my finger without having
to be worried about it people use this
in dark patterns or I don't know if
they're actually intentionally being
evil or if they're just ignorant but
you'll see pop-up ads on mobile where
it's got a tiny little X and it makes
you actually click on the add instead
but if you love your users and you do
because you're here at CSS conf Apple
and Google recommend a minimum 24 pixels
for an interaction target so 24 by 24
microsoft recommends 26 pick one go with
it and at least things will be better
when you're getting into really tight
you eyes and even but I'm desktop this
makes things easier if you're using a
mouse it's easier to click on the thing
regardless of how you're interacting
with your device making elements or
interactive elements larger makes them
better color contrasts usually see as an
issue Harrow plate when you get your
eyes tested when you're younger or
something that you might encounter color
blindness and the whole point of initial
haro plate is some colors don't really
gel very well with each other and
contrast don't work very well really the
cure load when you read into how color
blindness affects people the way to fix
it is to ensure that the elements have
enough contrast from each other so that
irrespective of being able to perceive
the colors you can still tell the
difference so anyone who's colorblind
along the wrong spectrum or right
spectrum will have trouble reading this
this is hard to read anyway even if you
do have perfect color vision because the
contrast is intentionally difficult
fortunately getting the w3c have done
the work for us they recommend contrast
ratios for 21 or four and a half to one
for small text at less than 20 points
and three two one for anything from 20
and up so that's great you know what to
do the problem is how to actually test
for it
the good thing is there are some really
good browser plug-ins this is the one in
Firefox this is the WCAG contrast
checker I have it alt see I hit and it
just comes up and you can test things
really quickly fortunately the w3c site
passes the contrast checker partly
because they're designers so bland that
you know here hope it does you can see
up here that the the contrast ratio is
there the luminosity so it shows you
exactly what passes and what fails it
gets a bit more complex when you're
dealing with background images and most
checkers don't do this very well because
when you have a variable background do
you need to basically measure every part
of it this site actually let's that lets
he do it so you can put an image in
there you can put the text on top and
I'll tell you whether or not it is going
to pass or not the difficult thing is
when you're first starting out doing
color contrast properly is getting into
the rhythm of it because designers don't
have very good tools for actually
measuring contrast so what you really
need to do is talk to your designers
frequently when they give you something
test it out and see and talk to them and
show you them and work out what the
answer is going to be once you get used
to how contrasts work you'll be able to
see what is a good contrast or not
without having to do a test I mean you
still test anyway to confirm but when
you get into the habit of it and becomes
much easier it's certainly difficult at
first and especially so for designers
because the tools are just lacking but
color contrast is more complex than that
this is a blog posts from Ryan Fredrik
at Shopify and they started looking at
the ratios and they're fixed ratios and
humans are not robots where organic
creatures we see the green spectrum
particularly well we perceive other
colors better or worse according to what
we're designed to do in nature and that
means you get things like this where
we've got a failure over on the left
and a success over on the right yet
perceptively the one on the left is
probably a little that's your right
anyway the white text is somewhat better
to read in certain circumstances so the
algorithm itself is not quite enough
like the simplicity of what the w3c are
doing isn't necessarily perfect and the
Shopify team looked into this further
and they found a 1992 highway manual
talking about the legibility of signage
and they've done the research there are
there's maths I'm sorry to introduce
maths in the morning but this actually
shows that the white on red is more
perceptible for for human interaction
basically than the black on red even
though it's the other way around when
you use a simple formula so if you're
getting into this and you're really sure
that your color looks good even though
the w3c tool tells you otherwise then
dive a bit deeper and you can come up
with some really interesting designs
buttons annoy me greatly when iOS 7 came
around everything went flat and flat
meant that we don't know what we're
clicking on on interacting with any more
google followed suit with material if
you use later and we've got our three
buttons that this one's all right middle
one you can see it's button e the one on
the end what is that like is that just
text on the screen how I meant to know
whether I meant to interact with that or
not I'm just going to leave that alone
and not touch it because it might do
something bad this is a really really
bad trend and we frequently follow like
humans of pack animals we follow
everyone else's example of what to do
Google write something Apple write
something we just do exactly what they
do without question but this is not good
because there's nothing inviting about
that button there's nothing to tell me
to make it
obvious you can get context within
positioning on the screen and certain
habits will form but there's nothing
inherently button II about it
fortunately with a lot of open source
style guides lately we've got some
really good examples of what to do the
really basic level is you need some
outline around the target so I know how
big the thing is am I going to tap over
here or there or where when you've got a
border you know exactly what you're in
for it makes it much easier to interact
with something this is from the US
government web design standards I
haven't looked at the site since Trump
was passed it's probably all in flames
at the moment I don't know there are
lots of good examples of what to do with
buttons out there keyboard access this
is something that gets neglected quite a
lot because it requires some effort
fortunately the efforts not that much
usually for keyboard access of UI
controls you need tab enter an arrow
keys or space as well you don't really
need to do all that much and once you've
written it for one control you can
coffee those patterns and might using a
library and reuse it everywhere else as
well fortunately we live in a world
where run shares everything Remy chef
has done the work for you I thought tabs
how hard can tabs be tabs can be very
hard so Remi wrote this article how tab
should work when I look through it it
didn't quite do everything that I wanted
to so grabbed his code and modified it
I've got a blog post that says how tab
should really work but I'm not Remy
sharp so you haven't read it before this
is my code example of the tabs that I
wrote again this is demos here we're at
CSS conferred most CSS is minimal really
bad I basically done enough to show how
things are interoperable here and no
further than that so this is when the
page first loads sometimes you'll see
can't handle multiple sets of tabs on
the
green or so come on learn how to use
javascript properly so here I've
selected the second tab I've now got
focus on the second tab my contrast is
really bad I'm sorry so you probably
can't see that very well and this is
where the keyboard now basically kicks
in and then I can use arrow keys and
there to navigate between tabs which is
really good so we'll pause and reflect
with a kitten for a moment because up to
hear you've basically done everything
which is great but once you've reached
this point you need to think that little
bit further which is to make sure you
don't mess with the environment that
you're in when we're writing things at a
custom if using a form control like I
select it's built into the browser the
behavior behaviors are non when you
write something on your own then you
need to bring it up to that standard or
don't ship it and that means you need to
respect everything that the browser does
what you need to do is be able to go
backward and forward in a browser
without stings stuffing up I should be
able to hit a hash somewhere in the URL
without it breaking angular or any
javascript libraries angel is bad even
react did this early on where if you
have at two hashes in the urologist it
kills the framework which it stops the
rendering they've fixed it angular is
kind of catching up but anyway you need
to be able to refresh the page and the
tab i selected last time is still
selected by it why can't these things
just be done but it's not that hard most
of how this works is but in this
particular instance you can refresh it
and a tab stays oh there's an API for
that it's the storage API that's been
there for a while no one really knows
about it but it takes care of a lot of
the problems that we usually have with
remembering things filling out a form
you get an error it reloads the page and
everything you've filled out it's gone
because no one knows how to do this but
storage lets you do all of that on the
client side without a pro
it's really really powerful but the
essence of it is to make sure you don't
kill what sorry there you maintain the
standards of what things should do and
it's not good enough to say that oh I
know everyone's going to have JavaScript
turned on so you know it's all going to
be fine all my users have got perfect
vision I've asked them it's all right
you need to actually think that little
bit further and it's really what
Universal Design is about is building
things for everyone anyway because
that's just the better way of doing
things a lot of accessibility talks use
a lot of stick where they're just
telling you a bad person if you don't do
this thing I'm trying to give you a
carrot here to make you feel better
about just making your code better the
fact it's accessible and people get to
use it is a bonus it's just a better
quality product that you'll be producing
and universal design has gone into other
fields this is a whole range of
prototype peelers and finished products
that were the first product from ox 0
and Sam Farber founder noticed that his
wife feels quite athletic and had
trouble using a kitchen peeler and it
was like well that's not good and he
went to the shop and there was nothing
he could find that did the job so he
iterated through several designs and got
her to test it out and this is designed
only for his wife I've got oxide product
so I had no idea about this until I
actually looked into it I just thought
they were really well designed and
that's the essence of what this is about
making your products fit into the
philosophies of universal design will
make a better products inherently even
for people who don't have any special
needs so go forth with your inspiration
that you too can create a better kitchen
pillar regardless of how strange your UI
might be and your work will be a whole
lot better thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I do thank you so much Chris
that was an amazing talk on web
accessibility so do any of you have any
questions for Chris Zell will be giving
out the microphone has anyone want to
know about kitchen peelers yeah the
highway signs thing you had with the
leave it on for a bit the contrast
levels what were the numbers being used
in that was it because you're using some
color numbering system that I wasn't
familiar with so maybe I can talk about
after that but if you could share a bit
more about it i'll be helpful yeah if
you it's on the Shopify article actually
linked to that highway manual I can jump
back in the slides no I can't jump back
30 sides there we go I can't actually
remember the intent behind this is the
highway manuals quite detailed into
reflection of services and different
things like that that they take into
account but the whole point of this is
not just as simple as a straightforward
color contrast right thank you anyone
has any more questions for Chris anyone
what color should your kitchen tea lovie
all right then thank you so much Chris
okay can you please give another round
of applause for Chris
[Applause]
you